[Music]
joining me this week is a comedian and
actress and author and activist and a
Grammy and Emmy nominee Margaret Cho
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
which of those things do you like first
I feel like most comedians like comic
first yeah comic um and then you could
just say comic it's all yeah I mean it's
all I mean I just do comedy and other
projects I'll do acting stuff but
usually comedic roles my music and all
that stuff is comedy my writing is
usually comedy so comic usually covers
it yeah
is there anything that in this wild biz
of Hollywood that you haven't done I
mean even just looking at your Wikipedia
before you pretty much like reality TV
sitcom I mean look you've pretty much
done everything that one can do yes
I haven't judged oh I've judged RuPaul's
Drag Race no I haven't judged like a
like an x-factor or American Idol or
like The Voice right that kind of thing
would you like would you do like a Last
Comic Standing would you when you judge
other comics do you think that would be
you think we'll be fine I think that
would be cool although I'm not a hundred
percent sure it's an art form you can
judge against yeah comedy is very much
it's about going after a particularly
entry'
sort of judge overall criteria as you
could say an Olympic sport it's very
different right would be afraid of like
crushing a young comics dreams because a
lot of you they don't know what they're
doing today
you could be horrible at 18 but amazing
when you're 40 it takes a while it's a
journey and I think you just get better
with time in general most comics really
flourish over the years and so I don't
know like you never want to be very
critical
I never and yeah you know of people who
are just starting out because you want
to give them some space to grow and to
fly yeah so I want to talk a bit about
your comedy and your history and all
that so let's start with your personal
history you grew up in San Francisco yes
parents were first-generation immigrants
right
I'm confused by the whole first
generation secretary so they came from
Korea right so they are first generated
in the United States yeah and then so
I'm second so you're technically second
unless there's something that I don't
know no no I mean I was born here yeah
um doesn't that make me first I oh I
guess you're you were the first born
here yeah so I think I'm first so that I
don't know well we're in a lot of
trouble I know well don't worry the
YouTube comments will clean this up
right don't worry about that all right
but your parents came here you were born
here when you grew up in a really
interesting part of San Francisco at a
sort of interesting time contender well
I grew up in the 70s in the Haight
Ashbury which was very sort of burnt out
from the 60s there's a lot of burnout
there's also this huge influx of punk
rock which is just starting to happen my
parents had a bookstore in pulp district
which was the big game neighborhood
before the Castro it was pulled and so
they had a gay bookstore in the middle
of that neighborhood so I grew up around
a lot of different influences both sort
of rock-and-roll and punk rock and also
from the gay world there so it was a it
was a cool place to grow up for sure
yeah how did your parents who were so
they were the first immigrants let's say
whether that's first or second but how
did they end up with a gay bookstore
they bought it they wanted to buy a
bookstore in a very cosmopolitan area
this was a world that they felt like
they didn't know anything about and they
were excited about it they wanted to be
a part of it and certainly the bookstore
was this crossroads of a lot of
different worlds are all kind of
pertaining to literature and art and
music and like there was book signings
by Armistead Maupin there who wrote
tales of the city there was a lot of
people meeting there and hanging out it
was social media before social media
people would check into the bookstore
right it was actual social media yeah
before it was all on the phone but do
you think there was something really
special about that
I'm there I mean even hearing about a
gay part of San Francisco before the
Castro it's sort of like I didn't even
know that really exists yeah it was
there and it was a very difficult time
because in the 80s
that's when aids really hit that
community hard and so you really saw the
devastation firsthand and and that was a
really sad thing to witness and grow up
in I know that a lot of the people
around there didn't make it and you know
because that was the community that was
first hit by AIDS like very strongly of
course there's New York but then San
Francisco really it really felt it and
it was really really hard yeah for you
growing up and so your family they owned
a business but you were still sort of
the other which I think has sort of been
like a theme throughout your life do you
sort of from being Asian to being LGBT
are you bisexual is that even like I
feel that I'm so tired of labels all the
time it like seemed silly I'd have to
ask
yeah I'm bisexual but I think even that
sort of makes you other within the gay
community there's not as large of a sort
of a voice for the bisexual community
and and so it's it seems like it's
growing but it was very new when I was
young certainly yeah so then you started
doing stand-up and you eventually got a
sitcom on ABC all-american girl I
remember watching it I think I watched
the first episode what what year was
that
1994 94 so that's like another lifetime
ago probably and the reason I wanted to
focus on a little bit is because it to
me it captures so much of what's going
on in the country right now with
identity politics and outrage and
stereotyping and all this stuff so ABC
comes to you they say alright we like
your standup we're going to we're going
to give you a sitcom what's that process
like well it was like this very very a
big deal because they were doing that
like a lot of sitcoms were based on
stand-up comics like there was a
huge amount of success around Seinfeld
and Roseanne of course and then Tim
Allen which was on our network so you
know it was about developing with
somebody and you know he didn't really
sort of take my stand up and use that as
material in the show because my stand-up
comedy was so risque and so out there
there was no really no way to fit it
into the sitcom format we were in the 8
o'clock hour it was a family show and I
was just trying to make that work you
know but I'm really proud of the show I
felt like we did a lot of great things
and you know we had a lot of issues with
the Korean community at the time because
the LA riots just happened to the Korean
community were incredibly intensely
sensitive about their portrayal in any
way and I think they didn't like the
fact that I was a woman they didn't like
the fact that I was this dirty comic
they didn't like the fact that I was
kind of talking about this Americanized
vision of a Korean family and so this is
where we bet heads a lot I mean but what
was great is there was a whole
generation of young people who got to
see Asians on TV for the first time and
that was really what had sort of the
lasting reach of the show so is that
like the ultimate irony of doing
stand-up sort of is like you do this act
you hone this act you were dirty and
raunchy and telling your truth as it is
then you have to go through like the
cookie cutter machine of ABC they kind
of clean it up and then still to a
certain percentage of the Korean
community they're going well she doesn't
maybe look exactly like what there's I
read talking about how one of the
executives wanted you to they thought
your face was too round I mean yeah I
was crazy stuff I just had all these
problems but it ultimately kind of came
down to people needing to constantly
create sort of critiques about it
because they've never seen an Asian
American family on TV before and it was
so hard but you know what happened was
the show was on for a year and then it
was cancelled but
the resounding power of it it's still
like had people thinking we'd love to
see this again we'd love to see another
Asian American family unfortunately you
didn't happen until just recently the
profession like a year ago right yeah
yeah um are there things that you maybe
would have done differently do you think
or do you think it was just the timing
of everything just sort of made it that
timing of it was really hard I I don't
know what I could have done differently
I mean I really don't like I have no
sense of what I could have done but
what's great is the show had a long
legacy and we see it today and fresh off
the boat or dr. ken or Kim's convenience
which is a show that's in Canada right
now which is all about an Asian American
family there too which is really or
Asian Canadian family its North American
family so it's it's a crazy how we get
so lost in these words like even as
saying that you are not American there
Canadia like everywhere yeah how is that
though for for you like it you've been
part of what you know people just get
outraged all the time about everything
do you have to watch your word sometimes
you're you don't really watch me I don't
really think about it I mean I just want
to do comedy and comedy in itself is a
noble art form there's like this sense
of you're just trying to make people
laugh and there's got to be something
very valiant about that and so I don't
really question it too much yeah who are
your comic heroes when you were growing
up I loved Joan Rivers I'm just the best
ya know we desperately need her now
she's one of them her and Carlin all the
time I'm always like God in these days
yeah and Richard Pryor sure I love I
love all of them Robin Williams also
incredible so him a lot and I love him
he was the best
but Joan Rivers certainly paved the way
for all women and you know really was a
very good mentor for me a very good
friend yeah you think certain comics
they just sort of have to
take it on the chin to make change
happen like she like Joan sort of had to
take it as a woman and mock herself as a
woman her looks and things like that and
even what you had to do with your show
like in a way you had to do that like
somebody has to sort of be thrown under
the bus in a weird way to get things to
change yeah I think so I mean but with
Joan it was incredible because her
trajectory through through show business
but so it was so varied you know when
she started doing comedy on TV she
couldn't talk about the fact that she
was pregnant yeah like that was a real
taboo and then juxtaposed with her
nightclub act which was as dirty as can
be like you know even when I would go
see her I would be blushing like it's
hard to make me offend I was like that's
offensive right I love that about her I
love being offended by her continually
over our long friendship it was the best
yeah is there anything that's too
raunchy for you or too politically
incorrect or any of that stuff oh no I
don't think so I mean I saw you I saw
you do stand-up in I think Atlantic City
Sandra Bernhard is opening for you she's
great I love her and you did a whole
thing about drinking olive oil oh yeah
how it yeah oh it's all that to me it's
very basic humor yeah it's like very and
he's our digestive it is hilarious but
yeah I I just I'll just sort of do
whatever but I love comics who can
offend me that's the best feeling yeah
why are people so offended though all
the time like you're offended for the
right reason I like oh I like it I'm
like how dare you uh
yeah what happened though that where
people think that somehow words are
going to destroy them that's what I
think we're at right now I don't know
there is some truth in that words can't
hate space hate speech can be harmful
and that certain ideas when you minute
diminish you human beings and sort of
talk about them in a way that's
dehumanizing there is a lasting effect
to that and and certainly the language
can be powerful in that regard but at
the same time when you're just having
fun you know and it's just comics having
fun I think I don't know I always sort
of enjoy that more than my tendency to
want to be offended yeah
do you think that phones change the
stand-up thing because I know from when
I started stand-up like nobody at a
phone in a room right nobody was
recording you the whole time or half the
time just looking down and you know yeah
but that you know anything you say in
standup where it's it should be the most
Ross form of what you do in your you're
playing with it to perfect it that now
people can be recording you the idea
does that ever happen to you yeah I mean
I'm sure it does I don't really care I
mean I I maintain a high standard as
much as I can and I do shows like every
day like multiple times a day
I'm very invested in the art form it's
very important to me but yeah sometimes
people record sometimes people aren't
paying attention which is more offensive
than recording like you're killing and
there's one guy looking at his phone and
focus that's so weird cuz you just see
this blue light and I don't I don't
really I don't care you know it's their
loss it's not important to me right
whether they witness what I'm doing or
not but yeah it used to be where you
could sort of say anything get away with
anything and you know uh there's so no
witnesses but there's always witnesses
yeah I don't know so just let's shift a
little bit to some stuff that's going on
right now so you had this email exchange
with Tilda Swinton do you want to just
kind of explain what happened so that I
don't put words into your mouth um so
Alex Borstein who plays mr. Swan yeah on
MADtv connected me and Tilda
she wanted to talk about Doctor Strange
she was playing an Asian role yeah and I
just was trying to sort of brick down
like well people are angry because they
feel that Asian actors should play Asian
roles because this is something that's
been going on forever in Hollywood so we
just talked about it and then I talked
about it on Bobby Lee's podcast who's a
friend of Alex's and and mine and so
we're talking about it and so then she
um
sort of posted all of the emails which
just sort of illustrates our
conversation how it really I don't know
a five i felt like very weird like why
are you asking me about this it's like
almost like i can't really back you up
on this decision to play this role like
i i don't know what to say to somebody
who doesn't accept or doesn't understand
the idea of whitewashing or that you're
part of the problem and so whitewashing
for people that don't know is basically
when they have a white actor playing
because there's so few roles for Asian
actors and I would really hope that we
would get to play ourselves at the very
least yeah so without getting into the
minutiae because I read the exchange and
I actually didn't think it was that it
wasn't hostile in any way I thought you
were both being totally respectful with
each other maybe or maybe we're slightly
missing some you know innuendo or
whatever in terms of just the acting and
all that how important do you think
visibility is actually it is it's
usually important I mean it's usually
important in it it's like there's just
really no sense of real respect for
Asian actors or an Asian audience or
even any audience who would prefer to
see an Asian character be played by an
Asian actor that's like just very night
normal to me we don't accept blackface
in any of its forms yeah in film or
television why would we accept yellow
face it seems to be happening
continually yeah so when I was doing a
little research on this I kept partly
thinking that in a weird way when people
think of the Asian community whatever
that whatever that is they think well
they're focused on education they're
focused on work that would sort of be
the the better way to go about doing
things right um not to say not to say
that exposure isn't important to but
that the community itself is sort of
focused on the right thing of how to how
to become success
does that make sense or they're they're
focused on arenas where they've seen
other Asian Americans achieve success
that's that's interesting that's where
we need to shift things and allow people
to be able to be themselves yeah and
involvement in the arts is very
important and and diversity arts exists
it's just the powers that be who control
the sort of the purse strings for the
large productions yeah
don't necessarily think diversities is
anything we should pay attention to and
they're seeing now with the advent of
social media that they have to pay
attention to it yeah how much of it
agenda do you think Hollywood has I
always think I at the end of the day
they're really just a business right do
you think they really make decisions
based on all on gender and and color and
all that like really like consciously I
know you can't it's hard to do a blanket
no but they're they need to now because
the thing about it is there there used
to be a disconnection between what
happens on social media and who buys
tickets and now we know the social media
is exactly what derives who buys the
tickets yeah and why they're buying the
tickets and what they're going to see
yeah um so I think diversity has a very
very big part in the conversation of
what we're going to see in the film now
and I love that yeah so how much time do
you devote to social media in general I
mean I see you tweet a bunch and stuff
like that but is it like consuming for
you that's a theme with a lot of my
guests like it's like take it over the
real life no no I live without any of
that I mean I am very involved in my
actual like real time like I got you a
life like real life yeah I very very
much limit my sort of my time on my
devices yeah you know because I just I
can get so into it and it's really
overwhelming and then when you're like
troll fighting and yeah how do you deal
with that kind of stuff I don't yeah I
don't know anymore like I don't care
I really don't care because it's not
important to me like I just have no
reason to want to go after people like
that because I have in the past and then
I've had other people who were backing
me up and then it became a whole thing
that I don't I don't know why this is a
fight you know this is not what my
intention is I just want to be a
comedian yeah so it's like not
interesting
right and it's sorta like you can't win
right like you can't you can't get into
a fight with the troll and come out at
the end either you've mocked them and
then it's like Margit Rosemont control
or you just end up wasting your energy
with them so they don't end game there
that's a way oh there's no win you know
it's kind of weird
[Music]
you
[Music]